[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau date année
d'interdire je reçois christian
graehling pour son livre le grand jeu
dans lequel il nous fait une lecture de
la géopolitique d'aujourd'hui la
chanteuse moonlight benjamin qui sort
vendredi son nouvel album see me do
c'est le mariage génial du vaudou
haïtien et du blues rock américain hey
je vais me vigne et le président de la
confédération nationale des charcuteries
des charcutiers traiteurs et oui c'est
la charcuterie aussi c'est de la culture
mais commençons tout de suite par notre
époque qu'est ce qui la caractérise
voici leurs réponses en images on
commence par la vôtre vous ne l'êtes bon
chemin
c'est haïti oui c'est haïti c'est à port
au prince et le move c'est le peuple qui
révolte qui en quête de lumière de
vérité le dire c'est votre don oui tout
à fait voilà ce sont des gens là qui
soulève un jour tous les jours pour
manifester pour sa maman seront lancés
ce moment j'ai mal c'est toujours le
carreau ça s'est passé c'est cbc mais je
pense que ça va revenir
on parlera tout à l'heure de haïti en
même temps qu'on parlera évidemment de
votre disque vous êtes haïtienne même si
vous vivez aujourd'hui en france je vais
me vider votre image à vous ça ça
symbolise le 21ème siècle pour vous vous
avez un pâté croûte dans les règles de
l'art voilà que du bonheur à partager
pour les grands moments
voilà c'est une oeuvre d'art et culture
quand vous le disiez oui oui on pourrait
même dire que c'est de la peinture
abstraite quand on le fait bien
néanmoins le pâté en croûte tels que on
le voit là il n'a jamais changé au moyen
âge c'était déjà comme ça le pâté en
croûte annoncé l'intérieur a pris qu'à
charger parce que c'est vrai que au
moyen-âge et avaient fusé avec les
moyens du bord et c'était à base de
cochon a priori là on est sûr de
l'élaborer de dû revisiter avec de la
volaille un peuple ait un petit peu de
foie gras si on veut onkyo zitte est un
petit peu à faire non mais voilà
autrement sur la forme la forme c'est
celle ci c'est toujours les mêmes
et pour vous christian bering l'image de
notre époque celle vécue renard c'est
l'un à gourna parce que dans quelques
mois on va célébrer le 70e anniversaire
de son ascension par par une expédition
française d'ailleurs et au delà des
polémiques un peu gratuites et stérile
qui lui a eu quelques il y a quelques
années on sait enfin tous les éléments
montrent que karzaï et lachenal sont
bien arrivées au sommet donc c'était il
ya 70 ans le 3 juin
et oui le temps passe et bien commençons
[Musique]
christian gaming vous êtes professeur
d'histoire et vous publiez le grand jeu
chez elio paul legrand juste une
expression que rudyard kipling
popularisé au 19e siècle qu'est ce qu'on
entend par le grand jeu alors il ya eu
un premier grand jeu entre les
britanniques et les russes pour le
contrôle de l'asie centrale les
britanniques qui étaient installés aux
indes les russes qui descendait
justement vers leur empire des indes et
donc c'était une zone d'affrontement en
asie centrale
c'était assez romanesque parce qu'il y
avait des espions des explorateurs mais
le gros jeu c'est pas forcément la
guerre qui tousse et la géopolitique
course et la géopolitique ça s'est fait
de guerres de conflits de diplomatie
alors le premier grand jeux étaient
faits en plus d'alliances avec les
tribus locales d'exploration d' aventure
maintenant il ya un nouveau grand jeu
qui est un petit peu moins romantique
tout aussi romanesque mais moins
romantique et c'est l'affrontement on va
dire colossal entre la puissance
maritime américaine et l'eurasie la
masse continentale eurasienne parce que
c'est bon c'est le vieil antagonisme
termeer entre les les puissances
maritimes les thalassocratie et les
puissances continentales l'alpha et
l'oméga de toute puissance maritime
c'est de diviser le continent c'est de
ne jamais laisser un état avoir
l'hégémonie sur le continent quand
c'était d'apollon l'angleterre s'est
dressé contre napoléon
quand ça était hitler de la même manière
les habsbourgs avons effectivement
et aujourd'hui alors ce serait qu'ils
passent et les états unis contre
l'intégration donc aujourd'hui ça
pourrait être la chine ça pourrait être
la russie ce pourrait être l'europe
concernant justement le font partie de
l'eurasie donc la puissance maritime
excentré en marge de
du monde quelque part c'est ce sont les
états unis et les stratèges américains
sont absolument obsédé par ils le disent
d'ailleurs ils l'écrivent sont obsédés
par l'intégration de l'eurasie et donc
toute la politique américaine au delà
des différentes guerres locales mais
toute la politique américaine vise à
maintenir une eau ghazi divisé alors
leur art langue ça ce qui est aussi une
autre notion art langues comme le coeur
et le pays
c'est quoi le heartland le heartland
c'est ce que les stratèges l'anglo-saxon
d'abord britannique est ensuite
américains nomment le pivot du monde le
coeur du monde
aujourd'hui le heartland est occupée par
la russie explique que toute la
politique américaine est automatiquement
dirigé contre la russie mécaniquement
pas parce qu'ils n'aiment pas les russes
mais parce que la russie occupe se
rappelant de ce coeur du monde qui est
capable de créer les dynamiques pour
unifier leurs asie autour d'elle à quand
la chine d'un côté avec l'europe de
lauzach au moyen-orient tynan indiens
etc
toutes ces zones qui appartiennent à une
ceinture que ces mêmes stratège
appellent leur hymne landes serine
landes concentrent les principaux foyers
de population de richesse de production
d'énergie du monde europe moyen-orient
sous continent indien extrême orient et
donc toute la politique
enfin la pensée stratégique anglo saxon
est de diviser ces deux-là maintenir le
heartland isolé du rib landes
alors prenons l'ukraine dont on a
beaucoup parlé tout on parle encore un
peu moi aujourd'hui mais néanmoins assez
souvent pour vous l ukraine occupe une
case particulière en eurasie puisque
c'est leur asie qui nous intéresse elle
est dans le rythme landes
elle est dans le ring landes mais allah
c'est l'interface entre le riz blanc del
arte claude lacaze sud-ouest de
l'échiquier le passage en plus des
pipelines russe
on en reparlera parce que ça aussi c'est
de l'importance grandir hexion de
l'europe et le le prix les américains
appelait l'ukraine le 1er prix
c'est-à-dire à une zone stratégique à
faire entrer absolument dans l'otan pour
flanquer le heartland de très près vous
expliquer par exemple que vladimir
poutine ne veut pas du tout
l'indépendance du donbass par exemple on
croit qu'il le veut pas du tout d'après
vous alors pourquoi ne le voudrait-il
pas et quel serait son intérêt d'après
vous est-ce que le donbass ne fasse pas
du tout ces sessions de l'ukraine au
contraire que l'ukraine reste entière a
surtout pas parce que toute la
problématique de l'ukraine c'est son
entrée ou non dans l'otan c'est qu'en
fait elle choisit son camp aux robots
ennemis dans l'otan pas dans l'union
européenne dans l'otan le temps l'union
européenne c'est l'antichambre de l'otan
parce que vous savez que la charte
de l'otan dans son point numéro 5 je
crois spécifique un pays qui connaît un
conflit ouvert ou couvert sur son
territoire n'a pas le droit d'accéder à
l'organisation atlantique d'autres les
américains admettent eux mêmes font
perdre et perpétrer un coup d'état là
bas parce que le maïdan c'était un coup
d'état
les russes montréal pas une évidence ici
on ne dit pas ça tous d'état n'ont pas
dit si non mais enfin les stratégies
américain george friedman lui-même le
patron de stratford qui est une boîte de
prospective stratégique très très réputé
pour le politologue très réputé là mais
c'est le coup d'état le plus flagrant de
ces 25 dernières années donc et de
l'autre côté les russes ont réagi alors
déjà en prenant la crimée certes mais
ensuite en créant un conflit gelé dans
le donbass pour paralyser l'ukraine et
qu'elles n'entrent surtout pas dans
l'otan qu'il ya un conflit à l'intérieur
le cren en fait de pouvoir entrer dans
le temps donc ce que la charte
l'interdît ce serait trop simple si on
pouvait adhérer l etat est le temps
pendant qu'en des temps que je sois même
en conflit à l'est c'est exactement ça
ellle et routine ne veut surtout pas
l'annexion du dombass surtout pas il
veut le maintenir à l'intérieur des
frontières eux craignent elles avec une
large autonomie avec une aide militaire
d'humanitaire tout ce que vous voulez
mais à l'intérieur des fois le conflit
gelé c'est la même chose en ossétie ou
en géorgie mais ça c'est exactement ça
l'ossétie du sud et l'abkhazie en
géorgie la transnistrie en moldavie au
fossé la même stratégie côté américain
et côté russe
c'est ça les américains veulent arracher
l'ukraine à la sphère russe la faire
entrer dans l'otan de la géorgie
devaux comme comme la moldavie et les
russes veulent créer des conflits gelés
dans ces territoires pour l'ange les
empêcher d'entrer dans l'otan et alors
ce que vous appelez vous dans votre
livre le pipelineistan ce sont les
fameuses pas pleine rue ce qui partent
de russie pour fournir de l'énergie à
l'extérieur de ses frontières
c'est un pays en soi c'est une vie voilà
derrière vous qu'est ce qui la rend dire
là comment faut-il les regarder et quel
est l'enjeu
à la lumière de votre grand jeu mais
c'est la guerre énergétique et qui est
très mal comprise
à la fois par certains on va les appeler
les pros américains prime est entre
guillemets mais aussi par les
antiaméricains primaire qui pensent que
les états unis font des guerres pour
voler le pétrole non c'est pas du tout
ça
ils veulent contrôler les flux
énergétiques mondiaux pour contrôler le
monde sait kissinger qui disait déjà
dans les années 70 contrôler le pétrole
et vous contrôlez les nations donc les
américains ne sont pas des voleurs de
poules ils vont pas en irak ou ailleurs
pour voler le pétrole
ils y vont pour le contrôler et marie
maintenir un certain degré de contrôle
sur leurs alliés ou leurs rivaux donc
l'enjeu là c'est le contrôle des flux
énergétiques non pas des stocks
énergétique
les russes se construire des pipelines
ces gigantesques un peu partout comment
ça se traduit en termes de conflits les
russes essaye de faire de percer le
comment dire le continuant américains
autour d'eux pour faire entrer leur pipe
line dans le ring landes les américains
tentent de les bloquer pour empêcher
l'intégration énergétique de l'eurasie
comme ils veulent d'ailleurs empêcher
l'intégration économique ou commerciale
avec les routes de la soie chinoise qui
sont encore le parler parce que ça de
l'importance aussi quelques conflits qui
sont nés justement à vos yeux du pape la
liste on y en a plein en asie centrale
en tchétchénie en tchétchénie mais
szczesny cinq animaux c'était un cas
parce que le 'pipeline' qui a mené le
gaz caspien passé par grozny
les américains et ont soutenu la
rébellion l'insurrection tchétchène dès
le départ de la première guerre de
tchétchénie je le montre dans livre on a
des sources là dessus pour à la fois
alors à la fois affaiblir la russie mais
en même temps empêcher le passage de ces
richesses caspienne et construire eux de
leur côté
le btc qui est un énorme oléoduc qui
voulaient faire la même chose avec le
gaz mais ils ont pas réussi transitant
par des pays amis des etats-unis qui
est-ce qui gagne pour l'instant au
peuple est distant est ce que dans le
grand jeu est ce que dans la
géopolitique on peut côté ce qu'il ya
une ceux qui perdent c'est un peu
difficile à dire parce que bon la
réussit plutôt bien niant tu mets les
américains ont encore un
un certain pouvoir de pression on voit
avec le north stream 2 les américains se
mettent une pression intense sur les
européens pour qu'ils n'acceptent pas ce
gazoduc
apparemment ils ont plus ou moins réussi
sauf que normalement quand même le
danemark a donné son accord finalement
après d'intenses perse d'intenses
séances de persuasion américaine le
danemark a fini par donner son accord et
le north stream 2 devrait voir le jour
à la fin de cette année donc c'est
plutôt quand même la russie qui arrive
avec le torque stream avec les pipelines
vers vers la chine
ils ont un plan de construire des
départs plaignent aussi vers l'inde
ils sont plutôt gagnant mais les états
unis essaient de bloquer toutes les
toutes les tentatives cia lang alors
parlons des fameuses routes de la soie
chinoise est dans le nom d'un acronyme
et ne table on est l'acronyme que vous
utilisez beaucoup au bep ou air au bord
c'était l'ancienne acronyme en fait one
bale thuan road maintenant c'est une
stature une voiture une route
maintenant ça a été transformée parce
qu'en fait il ya une infinité de route
donc c'est l'intégration commerciale et
économique de l'eurasie cette fois
poussé par pékin procès par les chinois
l'un des cauchemars des strats quoique
vous appelez l'intégration c'est
l'unification au fond c'est que ça à un
moment où ces routes de la soie peuvent
s'aimer se prolonger par tous en or avis
oui c'est ça et est reliée relier ces
parties du rim landes proposé via le
heartland et sa unifierait l'eurasie ce
qui analyse mais on dit que ça
unifierait l'asie au bénéfice des
chinois à l'enrobé après il ya
différentes des cours
il ya différents critères qui rentre en
compte parce que évidemment ça
sous-entend que par exemple l'europe
soit ouverte et ne soit pas
protectionniste on a par exemple
certains certains courants politiques en
europe
ils sont à la fois pour c'est
intéressant parce qu'ils sont à la fois
pour l'unification de l'eurasie veulent
marginaliser un peu les américains
sortir de l'otan et c est en même temps
une certaine forme de protectionnisme
contre les produits gilles produits
chinois donc c'est un petit peu dans la
balance mais globalement ça intègre sam
est en connexion
c'est partie de l'eurasie comment est il
possible de s'y opposer
pour les américains si les américains
veulent s'y opposer comment peuvent-ils
faire une faune pression ils font
pression une pression diplomatique
intense sur sur tous les pays qui sont
susceptibles d'y participer sauf que
l'instant le succès très relatif parce
que les pays européens même leurs mêmes
leurs proches alliés ont des intérêts
économiques profonds et ont tendance à
quitter un petit peu le navire
il ya quelque chose dont on parle très
peu chez nous c'est l'organisation de
coopération de shanghai ocs
le csc le rapprochement entre la chine
et la russie
certains l'analyse en dix ans on a
repoussé les russies sont jetés dans les
bras des chinois on peut l'analyser
effectivement différemment aussi
néanmoins c'est quoi l'océan dont on ne
parle jamais chez nous cite une
organisation c'est une structure
diplomatique sécuritaire et peut-être
bientôt militaire on ne sait pas encore
qui couvre les principales puissances
razieh non russie chine mais inde et
pakistan qui sont entrés les stands asie
centrale et certains considèrent que
c'est au csc la future autant raziel
mais avec une puissance bien bien
supérieur comment expliquez vous qu'on
n'en parle jamais ici par ignorance
parce que parce que c'est moins
important que vous avez tendance à
penser il ya une certaine nuance
spécialement en france parce qu'en
france on a on a l'esprit plein de
belles idées politiques d'idéologie et
on ne voit pas on ne voit pas toujours
l'importance géographique par exemple le
grand jeu est très méconnu en france
quasiment personne n'en parle parce que
il ya des cours il ya une composante
géographique là dedans que l'esprit
français n'est pas enfin avec lequel
les français ne sont pas familiers les
anglo saxons eux sont très sont
conditionnés la pensée stratégique anglo
saxon est conditionné par par la
géographie ils connaissent le grand jeu
sur le bout des doigts comme les russes
et les chinois en france on est un petit
peu un petit peu à l'écart donc toute
l'eurasie toutes ces grandes structures
eurasienne sa part est peut-être un peu
lointain le nombre de rencontres entre
jean ping et vladimir poutine par
exemple devrait attirer l'attention
oui en même temps bon dans une certaine
partie des médias français ou
occidentaux en général poutine mons a le
diable il ne faut pas en parler il faut
le montrer quand il est en difficulté
mais pas quand ils bénéficient de deux
de ses rencontres avec avec les chinois
il ya une ignorance il ya peut-être une
volonté de ne pas en parler mais c'est
dommage parce que c'est là que se joue
quand même le dit même ici parce qu'on a
plein de photos de poutine avec jean
ping mais au lieu de les passer au nous
et passe par la parole et on n'osait pas
ils en sont à leur déjà en 2018
ils en étaient à leur 22e rencontres je
crois en cinq ans est absolument
colossal maintenant ils se sont
rencontrés encore un certain nombre de
fois et c'est eux ce sont eux qui qui
ont une partie du destin du monde est
entre leurs mains et le quad ça aussi on
n'en parle jamais bon ça c'est un peu
plus logique parce que c'est dans le
pacifique c'est loin c'est loin enfin ça
quand même du sens d'après ce que vous
dites le quad c'est une stratégie pour
pour quasiment autant de la chine
c'est du containment et autour de la
chine on va dire alors dans le coin dia
qui est inquiète les états unis bien sûr
en sont à l'origine même si
officiellement c'est le japon qui qui
est à l'origine du quad donc etats unis
japon australie inde
il s'agit les américains n'ont pas
réussi à diviser
affaiblir durablement le heartland
puisque maintenant la russie revient sur
le devant de la scène
ils ont ils perdent ils perdent du
terrain dans le riz blanc donc
maintenant la stratégie seo moins de
contenir le brasier notamment de
contenir la chine parle est donc vous
avez cette alliance maritime qui
regroupe ces quatre pays et qui quand on
voit les quatre pays c'est vraiment s'en
retournera quadrilatère qui entoure les
choix ont tous relâchés mais normal
l'australie est d'or fais énormément de
commerce avec la chine et l'inde aussi
même elle a des intérêts communs avec la
chine vous l'avez dire l'intérieur de 2
2 le cs
donc comme je dis dans le livre
d'ailleurs le quad à quatre roues bon il
ya deux roues voilées c'est-à-dire
l'inde et l'australie qui qui aimerait
bien se rapprocher de la chine et par
contre il ya deux roues très solide ce
sont les états unis et le japon puisque
le chapon et le vent rival de la chine
dans cette région oui donc ça devient
limite et mois à venir limité pour le
quad mais les américains n'ont pas que
le quad ils ont aussi leur base en corée
leur base explique ça parce que c'est
très important
les bases et les systèmes antiaériens
anti missile en corée
officiellement c'est dirigé contre kim
trois dynasties contre la corée du nord
voilà contre la corée du nord
mais officieusement c'est bien sûr
contre la chine donc les américains
utilisent très habilement un conflit
ancien est réel
contre la corée pour en réalité avancer
leurs pions dans dans le contexte de la
chine
la syrie la guerre aux scieries ça fait
partie évidemment pour vous du grand jeu
alors oui et non parce que je le précise
d'ailleurs dans le livre
las le moyen-orient à une dynamique
propre donc il a un pied dans le grand
jeu c'est clair mais un pied seulement
pas les deux il ya quand même des
dynamiques propres au moyen orient la
syrie ont le conflit ancien même toute
la problématique du moyen-orient on peut
la résumer en deux mots arc chiite et
heureusement on n'entend jamais parler
dans les médias il s'agit pour les uns
de couper cet arc chiite qui va de
l'iran au liban du hezbollah en passant
par l'irak et la syrie et pour les
autres les iraniens de le reconstituer
donc toute la problématique de la guerre
en syrie c'est ça oui et qu'est ce que
la russie fait là bas alors la russie à
ses intérêts propres la russie a bon
d'abord elle a ses bases en syrie la
russie dans la continuité historique de
son soutien au courant nassérien laïque
au moyen-orient soutien quasiment le
dernier régime laïque de
du moyen-orient c'est à dire la syrie
d'assad la russie craint comme la peste
une une infiltration par ses frontières
sud deux des djihadistes de leuilly etc
ou d'al qaeda d'ailleurs qui est présent
en syrie
donc là et puis en même temps la russie
est alliée à l'iran donc est d'un petit
peu l'iran dont on dansa dans sa volonté
de reconstituer leur shit mais moscou
s'opposent principalement à washington
et cherche quand même à remplacer les
états unis comme comme gérant ou co
gérant du moyen âge
vous avez l'air de dire dans ce livre
que la position russe o'brien orient n'a
jamais été aussi bonne d'eau qui il
aurait tendance à réussir ce sont les
américains eux mêmes qui le disent et
qui s'en plaignent 1 vous avez des revue
américaine foreign policy etc qui se
lamentent sur l'entrisme rue c'est
quasiment le remplacement alors qu'ils
exagèrent un peu les états unis ne sont
pas non plus partie du moyen-orient mais
sur cette montée en puissance russe au
moyen-orient haïti dont on va parler
avec moonlight benjamin c'est pas dans
le grand jeu mais tout ce qui n'est pas
en eurasie n'est pas dans le grand jeu
donc mais néanmoins pourtant il ya eu du
temps de la guerre froide
il y avait la guerre froide existait ou
sonia ribes et on était avait fait
partie des enjeux de la guerre froide
oui oui c'était c'était les alliances de
revers
de l'urss puisque les américains
s'introduisait en eurasie les russes
essayer de faire de faire l' inverse
après c'est intéressant parce que haïti
j'ai vu des photos ou les manifestants
il ya c'était il ya quelques années
avait d'aider des affiches poutine vient
nous sauver
à l'époque que avant que le socialiste
était devenu comme des devenu avant
là le l'affaiblissement du casse toi ou
en fait que les états unis se sentait
obligé de soutenir haïti parce qu'il
avait peur est ce que le à ce que les
partisans de casteau tout le système et
ce système apprennent en bradant le les
caraïbes
donc ils soutenaient les haïti pour
justement est contrecarré fidel castro
écrit que duval y était devenue très
féroce bon certains sert pour pas
duvalier tout ça mais indirectement
quand même vous et il y avait un enjeu
dernière chose vous faites le point un
peu comme amin maalouf dans son dernier
livre sur le naufrage de civilisations
sur cette année 79 ou en fait tout a
basculé
vous dites on un jour on parlera de 1979
quand on parle aujourd'hui 1917 un peu
année très importante très
sous sous-évalué par par le regard
historique
et pourtant c'est là que tout s'est
enfin pas tous mais beaucoup de choses
ça c'est un grand basculement c'est à la
fois khomeiny en iran
margaret thatcher
ronald regan l'entrée des russes en
afghanistan qui va faire éclater l'urss
le soutien américain
ça aussi on ne comprend rien par exemple
par rapport aux enjeux
on ne comprend rien au soutien américain
en pleine guerre froide
ils sont censés lutter contre le
communisme au soutien américain
l'alliance à la coquine âge entre les
états unis et la branche la plus extrême
du commissaire où il le voilà donc
continuer de siéger à l'onu alors ça
alors que kidd était même plus au
pouvoir et et en 79 les états unis
soutiennent la chine maoïstes qui
attaquent le vietnam pro soviétique
pour continuer dans la rupture sino
soviétique
on a bougé jean ski qui vont le les
vietnamiens j'ai une fille c'était le
ministre des affaires étrangères de
jamie kart wii le conseiller à la
sécurité nationale il
il avoue il a mais les états unis ont
indirectement soutenu les khmers rouges
est votre livre s'intitule le grand jeu
il vient de paraître aux éditions elio
paul ont fait une pause on se retrouve
juste après
[Musique]
la crise de 2008 arrive et à ce moment
là on s'aperçoit que les choses ont été
mal faites
on n'avait aucunement prévu des
scénarios de crise de défaut de paiement
tant qu'on maintient la grèce avec les
mêmes conditions qui ont provoqué cette
crise vous aurez le même système
il serait plus cohérent qu'elle reprenne
son existence en main monnaie comprise
mais je reprendre sa monnaie ne résout
pas tous les toutous les problèmes bien
sûr qu'il faut changer les hommes qui
dirigent parce que sinon vous ne
résoudrait rien en sortant de l'euro on
veut en fait forcé la marche du
transformation d'un pays donc
effectivement peut-être que certains
grecs ont envie de voir cette marche de
transformation du fonds est sans aucun
doute une grande partie n'ont pas envie
de cette transformation son entrée dans
l'euro est en grande partie responsable
de ce qui lui arrive
[Musique]
je
mais nous
[Musique]
à
c'est quoi pour vous fils république
éthique
écoutez c'est une république qui se
préoccupent de lutter contre la
corruption et contre la fraude fiscale
qui a conscience que c'est un enjeu
considérable
le coût de la corruption et est évalué à
pour la france chaque année à 120
milliards le coût de la fraude fiscale
entre 80 et 100 milliards chaque année
évidemment cet argent pourrait être
beaucoup mieux employé de la firme pin
up fillion la classe politique
rappelez-vous étaient sidérés ne
comprenait pas le problème parce qu'il
faisait tout ça depuis des années chaque
année on nous avons nous découvrons des
pratiques des combines et ccc sans fin
je pense que la population les citoyens
ne réclame pas suffisamment cette
moralisation le citoyen à une doit
reprendre sa place et doit sanctionner
les élus indélicats et doit promouvoir
au contraire ceux qui proposent des
mesures visant à éviter les abus
[Musique]
mes invités sont aujourd'hui christian
graehling pour le grand jeu je vais le
mauvignier le président de la
confédération nationale des charcutiers
traiteurs et moonlight benjamin vous
êtes haïtienne et vendredi sur votre
nouvel album see me do écoutez on
regarde tout de suite d'abord faut dire
je suis très très content de vous
recevoir parce que j'adore ce que vous
faites et et regardant tout de suite à
des extraits du clip
comment dit on accepte notre api d'apch
ap
[Musique]
m
bayrou
le monde
à
la donne
[Musique]
bon
bailly
tant qu il m a dit
on va
elles attendent
[Musique]
m
ou coin note stable
ouais nan shan
non c'est toi
la douane
[Musique]
pourquoi
m
[Musique]
moonlight benjamin vous marier comme
personne vaudou haïtien et le blues rock
du sud des états unis
voyez vous êtes la fille moyen de la
fille naturelle d'abeilles lincoln avec
une guitare électrique web entendu abbey
lincoln avec une guitare électrique mais
je trouve c'est une très bonne idée
comment ça vous est venue la musique
vaudou c'est quand même la musique des
esclaves et donc le bloso si finalement
et ce sont des voix qui n'ont jamais été
entendus donc je me suis dit pourquoi
pas les mariés en plus le blues vial de
cette musique traditionnelle qui vient
d'afrique
donc je disais pourquoi pas faire un
mariage avec tout ça et pour justement
et servir de support pour faire valoir
la culture haïtienne
ici un petit peu partout où je passe un
groupe dans le monde
moonlight fait votre véritable prénom
tout à fait vrai et il ya des prénoms
comme ce sont des prénoms je dirais
américanisé ou ou parce qu'on parle
français
oui oui après souvent ils donnent des
prénoms suivant la circonstance
c'est à dire que ça dépend si la mère a
eu des difficultés à coucher et 6 et des
croyants ils vont dire dieu était là
donc où il dit c'est dieu qui donne donc
l'enfant va ça va va s'appeler dieudonné
genre ou christ était là rester là donc
moi dans mon cas mon père lui larmes
il m'a donné ce prénom pour parce que
l'été parce que justement pour allez
prenez la parole de dieu de partout
c'est pour ça qu'il m'a donné vous avez
chanté à l'église d'abord j'ai chanté à
des brises et j'ai grandi dans une
famille religieuse protestante j'ai
beaucoup chanter à l'église
et puis après j'ai fugué vers l'âge de
17 ans 16 17 ans on va vous écoutez
maintenant interprété six bideau suivi
dos et un prénom c'est midas après
l'homme c'est aussi une petite retraite
album c'est le titre de l'album masse un
personnage imaginaire je le questionne
par rapport à la situation du pays
le pays qui n'arrivent pas à trouver à
trouver la lumière à trouver la vérité
sur sur sur ce qui se passe on vous
écoute et on en parle
[Musique]
m
bah
[Musique]
non
m
[Musique]
vous êtes de benjamin comment
expliquez-vous que haïti soit la dpi
peut-être le même le pays le plus pauvre
du monde est pourtant l'un des plus
riches sur le plan artistique c'est très
frappant quand on est sur 7 il
s'appelait autrefois l'île d'hispaniola
où il ya la fois la république
dominicaine et haïti
vous allez république dominicaine ils
sont beaucoup plus riches ils vivent
mieux que en haïti mais il n'y a pas de
musique qui a pas de peintres ya rien
vous passer une frontière il ya des
peintres il ya des musiciens il ya tout
ou direct comment l'expliquez vous moi
je pense qu'à y tire toujours à faire
avec
avec des dirigeants insouciant
incompétents qui fait que voilà le pays
n'arrive pas à avancer et aussi des
partenaires manipulateur oui mais
comment se fait-il qu'il ya une telle
richesse artistique
peut-être peut-être que cette richesse
il le voit pas et c'est parce que pour
qu'on fasse avancer les choses il faut
être conscient de ce qu'on a
ne pas chercher ailleurs parce que quand
on sait pas qui on est on peut pas
avancer
donc je pense aujourd'hui où depuis
toujours
haïti n'est pas au courant ne sait pas
exactement 2 n'est pas au courant de la
richesse qui est qu'elle a haiti cherche
autre chose ailleurs
alors ce qu'il ya tout et surtout que
haïti a été la première république noire
indépendante
d'abord toussaint louverture puis jean
jacques dessalines quand même pas que
les français 20 des salines ballet
français
toussaint louverture lui malheureusement
est fait prisonnier et va mourir en
france mais des salines ballet français
sous napoléon
alain obtient l'indépendance c'est la
première république noire indépendante
et encore aujourd'hui c'est un des pays
les plus pauvres ce sont les tragédies
successives d'haïti qui font cela il n'y
a pas que comme je devais le dire tous
et tous ces gens qui n'arrivent pas à
faire avancer le pays
c'est
un manque un manque de connaissances et
aussi la peur parce que cette
indépendance
on a eu cette indépendance mais on en
fait quoi qu'est ce qu'on peut faire de
ça on dirait ça nous est tombé sur sur
le dos sans savoir comment porter tout
ça et en plus on n'a pas été soutenu par
par cette décision de victoire et on a
payé cette dépendance pendant des années
mais c'est vrai que les français ont
demandé une énorme indemnité voilà très
très cher et très cher pendant pendant
ce mandat pendant des années donc là il
a été a été délaissé sur les tout sur
sur les trottoirs impossible il n'y
avait pas eu de 2,2 de lier des liens
commerciaux avec a été justement pour
pouvoir l'aider à s'émanciper
parce que c'est un petit pays dans le
sens où c'est un jeune pays
il a besoin de lumière parce que selon
lui cache de la lumière il va pas
pouvoir s'émanciper s'épanouir grandir
je voulais qu'on vous écoute tu as
chanté par au prince justement la
capitale d'haïti
c'était au studio ferber à l'arrivée les
papous bafouée attaquée mais à l'arrivée
del mar l m'attaquer mais moi
à l'arrivée les pétillon filtre
pétionville patrac mpm à l'arrivée
la ville pas attaqué
[Musique]
philippe daubresse pages les membres
mais beaucoup changé ma baffe montauban
torrance l'otan froide ou presque en
bouche des montants au pas à frapper
agamaka belle séance photo pour une
photo pour et pauvres
[Musique]
bouton
bon
[Musique]
photo ps pâtit google en france pas de
pass famille dément pas osé me direz man
band maniwaki watts et ron wood au point
ce matin l'amendement bottom up maman
pro 3
photo p
[Musique]
photo pr
vous l'êtes benjamin vous n'êtes pas
seulement une grande chanteuse est aussi
une véritable prêtresse vaudou vous avez
ça veut dire que vous avez été initié
oui j'ai été initiés savent plus de quoi
pardon ça implique quoi oui et parce que
je voulais j'étais en quête de de soi
même de moi-même et savoir comment
comprendre tout ce qui l'est tout ce qui
se passe dans l'univers
comment faire avec l'univers comment
communier avec les autres tout en étant
différent comment je peux faire je suis
plus au pays
accepter l'autre comme comme il est ne
pas imposer ma façon de faire ma vie ma
vision des choses de faire avec tout ça
ça m'a aidé de grandir est arrivé à un
point où est bien on est tous là il faut
vivre tout simplement
est ce que pour autant vous avez juré de
respecter la volonté des esprits par
exemple je respecte la volonté tout ce
qui est tout ce qui est dans la lumière
et dans l'amour y compris les esprits y
compris des esprits votre album le
nouvel album sort donc vendredi et vous
serez en concert c'est à montauban
vous y serez le 6 février à lautrec le
ced vous sera à paris le 19 mars
[Musique]
je vais me vignes et vous présidez le
cnct la confédération nationale des
charcutiers traiteurs vous êtes le
premier charcutier que je reçois dans
interdit d'interdire mais c'est une
émission sur la culture et même sur la
contre-culture donc vous avez tout à
fait votre place ici c'est le plus
ancien des arts culinaires dit-on la
charcuterie vous êtes d'accord mais
soi-disant soi disant on demande
toujours aux empereurs romains tout à
fait huit historiens s'accordent pour le
dire
donc on va pas on va pas le contredire
un point fait recruter traiteur c'est à
cuisinier comme les autres il y en a qui
disent que le charcutier et le plus
grand des cuisiniers un cd des chefs qui
le disent étoilé way dont will guy savoy
pas été bien informée
ça me va bien ça va bien mais surtout
c'est guy savoy et si ce débat après si
vous vous laisser on est tous frères on
est tous proches de de la cuisine
gastronomie cette culture française la
gastronomie quoi alors j'ai justement
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui votre votre
ennemi c'est la charcuterie industrielle
on dirait que c'est elle qui fait du
tort à la charcuterie il ya combien de
véritables charcutier en france les
charcutiers traiteurs vous êtes combien
aujourd'hui alors il ya 1 6500
établissements établissements voilà donc
davantage quand on compte tous ceux qui
travaillent à vous tout à fait après si
vous voulez mon combat c'est pas que les
industriels est parce que les
industriels ont les amis les amis à
place c'est l'économie du pays et
l'économie mondiale et qu'un te chante
un monsieur qui nous parle de 2,2 de
l'histoire et c'est madame qui on a on
est proche on a des liens au bout du
bout très proches et des combats communs
quoi mousse que je combats aussi c'est
pâques industriel c'est les revendeurs
de charcuterie qui aujourd'hui sauf dans
le passé pour des chefs entre temps à
chercher ce qui donne une mauvaise image
et est au bout du bout le consommateur
il est bluffé c'est plus vous avez vous
avez mis en place d'ailleurs ça fait un
moment déjà de mieux depuis 2011 cali
chef lamy
michel sait pas si on la lavalloise
s'est pas assez quoi c'est pour ça que
j'ai créée depuis l'année dernière pour
les nouveaux les arrivées les adhérents
de cette année le logo artisan
charcutier de france c'est le même
problème que pour les boulangers les
vrais boulanger qui en ont assez d'être
en concurrence avec des revendeurs de
pain tous accepterait des gens qui sont
est ce que le consommateur aujourd'hui
c'est on doit travailler pour le
consommateur de l'authenticité des
produits et malgré tous les efforts que
nous avons faits parce qu'on a été
attaqué aussi par la santé etc
le sel le gras ni trop nitrite de sodium
rite on en est plus là dedans on n'y est
plus on a baissé le taux de sel depuis
depuis 2008 on a baissé le taux de gras
on ne peut plus faire la charcuterie
1-1-2 sadao sinon il n'y a pas de
conservation je parle pas des produits
c'est ce savoir que le nitrite de sodium
dont on a beaucoup parlé c'est un
conservateur y compris un conservateur
de couleur oui douleur oui et c'est vrai
qu'il y avait un certain nombre de
charcutier même d'artisans charcutier
qui se sont se sont laissés entraîner
laissant traîner tout à fait et
aujourd'hui c'est terminé
quand on a en démonte on démontre que il
ya très peu de de charcuterie et moi je
prône que le salon frites et il existe
toujours et il existera toujours
il ya le botulisme il faut défendre
quand même réussi ça n'existe pas vous
qu'on fasse dans quelques cas mais
autrement ça c'est pas le sécurité qui
représente au bout du bout 0,07 par kilo
de produit et je le défend uniquement
pour les produits sont mûri bon donc le
jambon les jambes audio les choses comme
ça d'éclat mais après ce qu'on ne m'ait
pas nous les jeunes chercheurs de goût
l'aigu cause les polyphosphates ouais
donc on n'est pas dans un cadre de
certains maîtres un jambon de 6 kg en
cuisson et que quelques heures après il
a fait cette expliquez moi le problème
nous les artisans
on va mettre déjà des diamants qu'ils
vont faire 8-9 kilos et au bout du bout
on va perdre 15% la cuisson quand vous
imaginez
et puis après on n'est pas des sauvages
à bord il n'y a pas du fluo il n'y a pas
de l'humidité mais on dit aussi que
un jambon comme le reste de la
charcuterie ça doit devenir gris c'est
normal oui mais les consommateurs ont du
mal à l'admettre c'est pour ça qu'on
avait mis des conservateurs de couleurs
on veut que ce soit rose mais non ça
doit être gris au bout d'un moment ça
c'est la tête des gens ouais mais bon
voilà donc c'est faudrait l'enlever mais
là c'est l'europe qui va le décider
parce que c'est un as des textes en
france veut y avait des textes européens
donc si un jour l'europe dit on veut
plus de sécurité il faut aller au bout
du bout ce soit le consommateur il
acceptera lâcheté des hommes en gris par
contre les artisans notre jambon nos
produits charcuterie dans les 48 heures
il vire comme on le dit justement au
gris parce que y'a rien de plus pour les
conserver oui c'est ça la différence et
ça ne change pas le goût du pauvre
bouchons à 12 heures c'est pas salé des
heures bien ça le terreau est donc cette
fois le vent mais on le dit pour
expliquer au départ c'était que le port
que travaillaient les charcutiers oui
aujourd'hui tous les gibiers oui il n'y
a plus de limite on pourrait imaginer
demain d'aller jusqu'au bout poulets aux
ampoules et oui d'ailleurs aux neuf
pourquoi pas mais aujourd'hui vous savez
nos boutiques
le se sont elles évolué et aimer parce
que c'est le consommateur qui a demandé
à ce que ça évolue donc je lis ce métier
là il a la charge du tri mais derrière
aussi il à la cuisine est il malade
les salades etc allez les plats cuisinés
est parce que traiter ces traiteur de
boutiques
c'est à dire qu'on repartait avec un
menu complet la pâtisserie salée
l'apathie c'est sucré façon grammaire
etc
voilà donc vous arrivez chez nous vous
avez un ou deux invités un couple d'amis
tous deux couplés éviter le soit vous
passez chez nous vous repartez avec vos
feuilles avait il y avait chez blier il
y avait aussi les oiseaux
ça n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui les
charcutiers parce qu'il vous avez la
bécasse l'ortolan je sais qu'en tant la
droite mm là même les mêmes la bécasse
même avec 4
non les oiseaux jbc c'est très limité et
nous avons une énorme là dessus ce qui
est tout à fait logique
qu'est ce qui caractérise pour vous les
charcuteries française que ce qu'on voit
bien quand on mange de la charcuterie
italienne qui est aussi et également des
richesses ça n'a rien à voir avec la
charcuterie française qu'est ce qui fait
la différence pour vous et je parle pas
toutes les autres charcuterie basque il
y en a à peu près dans tous les pays
même si elles sont moins variées que la
nôtre ouais alors la charcuterie on
s'est vraiment français voilà vous
parlez d italie ou pas les a même temps
deux on peut parler de l'espagne dans
ces pays là on n'est plus dans ce
secteur petit insecte
après vous parlez on peut parler de
l'allemagne du danemark et la honda le
fut mais voilà après les autres pays
comme au japon en chine tous à onze on a
importé d'un portage a coûté le
charcutier la charcuterie française
éléments atypiques c'est vraiment le
travail la conception avec du hachage du
broyage et cetera de la mise au sel vue
de la cuisson donc tout ça de l'addition
de la créativité dans la charcuterie
française charcutier la charcuterie que
cuisiner un gros chez ces français
typiquement français avec 450 produits
quand même ouais et alors on voit bien
d'ailleurs rien il faut la charcuterie
c'est aussi une question de couleur
c'est souvent les mêmes couleurs le
depuis qu'il ya des salades dans les
charcutiers dans les charcuteries ça a
beaucoup payé
il ya de plus en plus de recherches
aujourd'hui pour accompagner pour que la
charcuterie soient accompagnés par les
légumes naturellement que cela devienne
comme on accompagne du boeuf avec des
légumes vous êtes partisan bossi
ne serait ce que pour des raisons de
couleurs tout à coup ça devient beaucoup
plus variés mais tout à fait de sa soeur
il faut éveiller un petit peu nos
produits déjà il ya quelques couleurs
qui résultent mais c'est vrai elles sont
assez sombres et en même temps aussi
on démontre avec les légumes ou même
avec des agrumes est quand même
conséquent pas que c'est que c'est light
oui c'est un plat c'est dire que ça ne
se mange pas seulement il du pain on
attend ça le pense oui exactement on
peut l'accompagner mais bon la bombe en
pleine campagne est bien fait ça c'est
de père ses deux paires même avec une
bonne bouteille boire avec modération
mais vous voyez là on est on est sur des
produits
on est vraiment sur les produits où vous
avez à l'intérieur sur ce rosé tout ça
c'est de la carotte
ouais on est que le vert que vous voyez
c'est du naturel s essaient de l'épinard
au bout du bout ouvriers mais voilà donc
tout se mange donc ces produits là il
doit être comestible de a à z
donc on leur donne juste une pointe de
légèreté en incorporant une gelée
travailler et des légumes à l'intérieur
moonlight vous habitez en france depuis
qualité dans le sud de la france est ce
que vous mangez de la charcuterie à
méjanes jeu j'aime beaucoup ça et on l'a
fait on fait le tue-cochon tous les ans
on fait le jambon saucisson pâté tout
frites ont vibré et
le canard c'est mais parce que nous on
nous nous faisons ça à la maison on met
pas de conservateur et ça tient des et
des années pour jupes à pâques ou deux
pour les peaux le saucisson parce que
j'attends pas même avant le séchage et
pourquoi on est obligé d'en mettre
et de mettre autant berne où les
artisans beau jeu moi je suis d'accord
et vous n'avez pas de conservateurs déjà
on n'avait pas ni bien des cas après
madame moonlight si vous permettez vous
travaillez des cochons qui font 100 82 5
kg voilà et ils ont été élevées pendant
dix ans au moins à la ferme d'accord
donc déjà cédé cochon qui sommes mature
et un qui semble bien me voilà on n'est
pas dans un cochon car au bout de quatre
mois fait 80 kg et donc les artisans
aujourd'hui c'est ce que j'aime pulsé
depuis plus d'une dizaine d'années
on travaille sur des cochons fermiers ou
sous des labels donc ils ont au moins 50
kilos donc déjà se rapproche donc nos
produits se conservent mieux parce que
la viande est bien tenue vous avez là
c'est la qualité
au départ donc vous avez je vous suis
vous avez entièrement raison de vous
poser cette question
ce que moi j'ai connu ça aussi chez mes
grands pas on accroche donadel là le
couloir où on pouvait n'importe quoi
c'était ça mais c'est au départ c'est le
bon produit
dernière question quand on est au cap
ferret par exemple on mange des huîtres
avec du pâté
c'est pour déjà fait des raisons oui un
très net
wimereux autrefois il n'avait pas le
droit de vendre leur suite s'il n'y
avait pas en plus quelque chose il avait
mis du pâté et il ya certes un
charcutier français gilles vérot
notamment qui commence à être associés
la charcuterie avec le poisson où vous
en êtes vous personnellement de ce côté
là moi vous savez que girondins oui
règle 2 que ça fait des lustres que nous
nous associons les huit avec la
crépinette voilà tu de forme de saucisse
ou avec une bonne mousse de foie aussi
et voilà donc que oui on est dangereuse
il ya toutes sortes de choses à faire de
ce très bel jours merci tous les trois
d'avoir participé à cette émission le
grand jeu de christian graehling est
paru aux éditions hélium
le nouvel album de moonlight benjamin si
mido sens vendredi elle sera en concert
à montauban le 6 février à lautrec le
set à paris le 19 mars au hasard ludique
puis entre-temps les etats-unis la
suisse la hollande etc etc
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]